Transcriptor: Andrea García
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Realmente cuidamos lo que nos identifica?
Esto que les voy a contar
no es algo que aprendí en los libros.
Soy Alejandra, soy arquitecta,
no soy de Concordia
pero es la ciudad que elegí
para vivir y para trabajar.
Como ya les dije soy arquitecta
y he tenido la suerte de poder pasar
más de la mitad de mi vida ya
haciendo lo que me apasiona
que es cuidar y crear
los espacios que la gente habita.
Pero también investigo, trabajo, estudio
sobre el patrimonio,
el patrimonio construido.
Aquellos lugares del pasado que deben
ser cuidados para que no desaparezcan.
Hace algunos años tuve la oportunidad
de participar a través de un concurso
de la consolidación y puesta en valor
de castillo San Carlos.
¿Castillo?, pensé.
¿No será demasiado pretencioso
decirle castillo?
Si pensamos en los castillos europeos
este no tiene murallas, no tiene torres,
no tiene fosos.
No tiene los elementos típicos
de un castillo.
Sí se puede parecer en cuanto
a la construcción,
el tipo de construcción,
de piedra y de ladrillo.
Y también los materiales que se utilizaron
para esas construcciones.
La mayoría traídos de Europa:
los cierros de Inglaterra,
los revestimientos de Alemania,
los mármoles de Carrara, las lámparas,
el mobiliario, los terciopelos de Francia.
Del lugar se utilizó la piedra arenisca
que se obtenía del río Uruguay.
¿Es una construcción importante?
Las iniciales de su propietario,
así como el año de construcción,
data de finales del siglo XIX.
Se encuentran en el portón de acceso
de la vivienda.
Es una vivienda importante
que tiene dos plantas.
Una planta alta donde están las
habitaciones principales de la vivienda.
Y una planta baja o semienterrada
donde se encuentran
las habitaciones de servicio
y las caballerizas.
Pero también, la importancia
radicaba en el aspecto comercial.
Esta casa fue edificada en un lugar,
a orillas del río Uruguay,
donde había un saladero, una fábrica
de conservas,
se iba a instalar la primera
fábrica de hielos de la Argentina
talleres de herrería artística,
es decir, se iba a hacer un lugar...
un nodo comercial y productivo.
¿Se encuentra en una
ubicación privilegiada?
La casa fue edificada en una de
las lomas más altas de Concordia
con una vegetación frondosa,
con selva en galería
y a orillas del río Uruguay
con vistas al Salo Chico.
Pero, en definitiva, no es
ni un palacio ni es un castillo
es una hermosa casa
con la piel color caramelo.
Pero, hagamos un poco de historia.
Esta casa, como ya les dije,
fue construida a finales del siglo XIX
por Éduard de Machy, un industrial
francés, que le decían conde,
aunque de conde no tenía nada.
La casa, ya dijimos,
fue destinada a ser, además de vivienda,
un lugar importante para la producción.
La vida de Éduard de Machy en este lugar
fue muy breve, apenas tres años.
Y desapareció misteriosamente;
por mucho tiempo no se supo nada de él.
Eso comenzó a tejer algunas fantasías
y leyendas en el lugar.
Luego, la casa pasó por varias instancias;
fue abandonada, fue alquilada, fue
vendida hasta que finalmente la adquiere
la municipalidad de Concordia
y la alquila nuevamente.
La alquila a la familia Fuchs Vallon
que fue una familia muy importante
para la historia de este lugar.
Era una familia francesa con gustos algo
extravagantes, criaban animales salvajes:
zorros, mangostas, serpientes, iguanas...
Un día las niñas de la familia
ven aterrizar un avión
en un tambo lindero a la casa.
Era nada más y nada menos
que Antoine de Saint-Exupéry.
Él en ese momento era piloto comercial,
había tenido una avería en el avión
y tuvo que detenerse en Concordia.
Quedó encantado del lugar,
volvió en varias oportunidades,
y se hizo amigo de la familia.
Ya en Francia escribió acerca de Era y
Sussan como las princesitas argentinas.
También, en "Tierra de hombres" escribe,
en el capítulo Oasis, acerca de Concordia
y hace una descripción
de la casa y del lugar.
Y, por supuesto, es el autor
de "El principito"
uno de los libros
más importantes del mundo
que fueron inspirados en estos lugares.
La casa, nuevamente pasado un tiempo,
queda abandonada.
Fue saqueada, comienza su deterioro,
va perdiendo lo que quedaba de ella:
mobiliario, cortinas, los mármoles...
Hasta crecieron árboles
adentro de las habitaciones.
Y hasta que un voraz incendio
en el año 1938
terminó con lo que quedaba del esplendor
de esa casa y se transformó en ruinas.
Pasaron 60 años para que
se decidiera el destino de esta casa.
A través de una consulta popular que
lo revisó la municipalidad de Concordia.
¿Era tan amada esta casa
por los concordienses
que no querían desprenderse de ella?
¿Qué tenía esa casa para
que quisieran conservarla
tal y como estaba hasta ese momento?
¿Por qué una intervención arquitectónica
tiene que ser puesta a votación
para poder realizarse?
Esas eran algunas de las preguntas
que yo me hacía a medida
que me iba acercando,
aproximando a la casa.
Y conociéndola.
Pasaron algunos años más
y se comenzó con las tareas
de puesta en valor del
castillo de San Carlos.
Esto se transformó en
una de las experiencias
más motivadoras de mi carrera profesional.
Se organizó un equipo de arquitectos,
de ingenieros, de arqueólogos y obreros
y comenzó una rutina
sin demasiados sobresaltos.
Comenzaron las obras, se comenzó a hacer
la limpieza del lugar, en primer lugar.
Una de las quejas más comunes
era escuchar a los albañiles
que se quejaban porque tenían que limpiar
piedra a piedra y ladrillo por ladrillo
el palacio de la reina, como le decían.
Pero, hasta acá veníamos trabajando
sin demasiados cambios
hasta que comenzaron a suceder
algunos hechos que les voy a contar.
Bueno, como toda obra,
se comienza haciendo un obrador,
una casita al lado del edificio principal.
Por ahí comentaban que se escuchaban
pasos de hojas, voces, susurros.
Escuchamos una voz de mujer, ahí
del otro lado hoy. ¿No era usted Doña?
Y resulta que yo acababa de llegar.
Una vez nos visitó un señor que
había vivido siempre en el lugar.
Cuando era niño jugaba en ese lugar,
siempre en la zona del parque,
y él nos aseguraba que en las caballerizas
había túneles, y nos señalaba el lugar,
y nos decía que cuando él con sus
amigos quería entrar prendían una vela,
porque era un lugar muy oscuro.
Se apagaba la velita y no podían seguir.
Nosotros nunca pudimos constatar
que efectivamente
hubieran ni túneles ni pasajes, ni
ahí ni en ningún otro lugar del castillo.
Otra cosa que pasaba bastante
frecuentemente
los que tenían que hacer
el cuidado a la noche del lugar
preferían hacerlo desde el lado
de fuera o adentro del auto.
¡Ni loco me quedo solo
allí adentro del castillo!
Yo no le encontraba demasiada
explicación a todo esto.
Yo escuchaba, cada uno
manifestaba sus experiencias.
Quizá podía tener que ver con
la partida abrupta de Machy.
Todas esas leyendas que se
fueron tejiendo alrededor.
Hasta que un día,
cuando estábamos limpiando
las caballerizas
que es actualmente
el centro de interpretación,
un lugar que estaba
repleto de murciélagos,
aparece en un rinconcito
de la bovedilla del techo
una carta de amor.
Si Uds. me preguntan qué fue
lo que hizo en mí que yo cambiara
mi forma de mirar
y de acercarme al castillo,
y casi adoptado como propio, yo no sé.
Tiene que ver seguramente con toda
esa fantasía, con toda la magia del lugar,
quizá por lo que inspiró a Saint Exupéry.
Pero ahí entendí,
entendí los secretos
que guardan las paredes.
Entendí por qué la gente
quiso cuidar y proteger las ruinas
del castillo San Carlos
por una consulta popular.
Entendí las leyendas.
Y lo que inspiró a Antoine de Saint
Exupéry para escribir "El principito".
Pero más allá de todo eso
yo los invito a pensar.
Cuando Uds. tengan la oportunidad
de conocer un edificio,
cualquiera sea y
en cualquier lugar en el que esté,
no se queden solamente con lo construido,
porque un edificio es mucho más de eso.
Hay historias, ahí vivió gente,
pasaron cosas.
Los edificios tienen
más que una historia para contar.
Por eso, yo los invito a que
aprendamos a ver con el corazón.
Porque lo esencial
es invisible a los ojos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)